Oh
you
we're fortunate to have Harvard's
foremost X foremost expert on dignity
here Donna Hicks is associate at the
Weatherhead center for international
affairs at Harvard University speaking
next she has been involved in numerous
unofficial diplomatic conflict
resolution efforts including projects in
the Middle East Sri Lanka Cambodia
Colombia Cuba and North Ireland Northern
Ireland she was a consultant to the BCC
to the BBC where she facilitated a
television series facing the truth with
Archbishop Desmond Tutu which aired in
the united kingdom and on BBC world she
has taught conflict resolution at
harvard clark and columbia university's
and conducts training seminars in the
dignity model a human centered approach
to rebuilding conflict relationships in
the US and abroad she's the author of
the book dignity it's a central role in
resolving conflict published in 2011 by
yale university press and is the founder
of declared dignity calm so dr. Hicks
what exactly are we learning about human
dignity that can inform in very concrete
ways the development of trust and
ethically healthy organizations in ways
it might be consonant with humanistic
management as dr. Pearson describes it
yes thank you Bill first it's I feel
privileged to be on this panel with with
all of my colleagues and I think I'm
going to take a slightly different tack
than what what they have because I
consider myself a scholar practitioner
and I'm going to emphasize more my
practitioner understanding and my
practitioner role today so I'm going to
start by just by way of background
explaining as bill mentioned I've been
working for the last 25 years in
international conflict and was had been
bringing parties together for dialogues
for in order to try to resolve the
political issues that divided them but
while I was sitting there at these
tables as a third party trying to get
them to come to some agreement about how
to resolve
these these these differences what I
realized largely because I'm a
psychologist is that there was another
kind of conversation that was taking
place at the table but it wasn't about
the political issues that divided them
and no matter where I was in the world
this other dimension of the conflict was
popping up and just because I have so
little time I'm not going to go into
much detail about it but let me just say
that it was a profoundly emotional
dimension that was never ever being
discussed at the table but in my view it
was running the running the conversation
and so just the short story is this this
emotional conversation if i were to put
words to it and it would say something
they would be saying something like how
dare you treat us this way right don't
you see where human beings can't you see
that when you treat us as if we were
second-class citizens earth if we're
less than that it affects us can't you
see we're suffering and so very long
story short it took me a while but I
figured out that this was all about
their dignity and how they were being
treated by the other side and I think
this is the the really important aspect
of dignity that I'm going to focus on
here is that it's about the relationship
about how it's not so much about how
individuals what their needs are but
what is the nature of the relationship
between people that either makes us feel
great makes us feel like we're being
seen being heard being responded to
versus makes us feel small and
diminished and degraded and less than so
going to quickly tell you what my
definition of dignity is because I think
this is part of the part of the problem
here is that we don't really have a
really strong definition but after
researching this topic now for you know
almost two decades I've come up with a
very simple definition and I think
Michael will appreciate this because I
realized when we're talking about highly
charged emotional events like dignity
that's simpler the better because the
brain that gets engaged and we think
about our
and think about our self-worth is not
the sort of executive analytical brain
this these issues of dignity are really
deep in our souls and it requires very
simple words and very simple ways of
explaining it and so for me the very the
one thing that we are that dignity
really highlights is the fact that we're
all born inherently worthy every single
one of us no matter where we're from we
are all born worthy and valuable now
that's easy enough to imagine but the
second half of the definition i think is
the more important one for us here
dignity is about that our vulnerability
as well human beings this is what we're
learning about what it means to be human
that is so central to dignity that human
beings while were born equally valuable
and where they were also born vulnerable
to having that dignity violated and this
is where all the problems occur and what
I realized was that this this desire
this yearning to be treated with dignity
was universal everybody no matter where
I was in the world everybody was
clamoring for the same thing treat me as
a human being of value and Worth and and
there's so I mean there's so many things
to tell you about this but let me
suffice it to say that I believe it is a
universal concept it's out the hallmark
of what it means to be human is that
common shared yearning to be treated
with dignity to be treated as if we're
something of value and as i said earlier
when we're not all all sorts of horrible
things happen when we perceive that
we're not being treated with dignity
whether it's in the workplace whether
it's in our families whether it's in our
international relations this is the the
common denominator so what does it mean
what does it look like to honor dignity
i'm going to give you 10 ways that i won
my research has shown that there are 10
ways that people universally want to be
treated with dignity and first of all
they people want their identity accepted
no matter who they are they don't want
to be treated as
you know in a biased or discriminatory
way we all want our identity accepted we
want recognition recognition of our
unique qualities and ways of life we
want acknowledgement and especially we
want acknowledgement when we've suffered
and we also want acknowledgement when
we've done something really wonderful so
human beings crave that that that sense
that somebody else out there is seeing
and acknowledging who i am what i'm
doing and what i'm about inclusion well
in a workplace in all in all
organizations actually people want to
feel a sense that they belong and if you
don't if you feel like you're on the
margins of that if you feel like you're
being left out of that sense of
belonging it's a terrible place and
people feel like it's a violation of
their dignity safety oh here's the big
one for the corporate world folks we all
understand that we need to feel
physically safe that's nothing new right
we have a legal system that protects us
against of being physically harmed we
had a whole healthcare system that takes
care of us but safety psychologically
when we feel that we are dignity as
being compromised when we feel that more
psychological deeply spiritual sense of
who we are is being violated we end up
feeling shamed and humiliated that's the
kind of safety I'm really focusing on
here and also the safety to feel to feel
safe enough to speak up when something
bad is happening to us in our
environment and by the way when I've
done all my corporate work this is the
key element that people complain about
they do not feel safe to speak up
especially to their bosses when their
dignity is being violated independence
well that's freedom we all want a sense
of freedom we don't want to be
micromanaged we don't want to be are to
be restricted in any way we want to be
understood so understanding is a key
element and I can tell you from working
in the conflict world for as long as I
have most one of them almost all the
time both parties and both sides of the
conflicts never feel adequately
understood
benefit of the doubt this is the ninth
element of dignity benefit of the doubt
we all want to be treated and approached
as if we were people of integrity and
giving people the benefit of the doubt
is actually a way of saying yes I'm
going to start out and I emphasize start
out because people always say to me but
what if you know the person isn't really
trustworthy what he going to do but
benefit of the doubt is a way of
initially showing that person that you
think that he or she is worthy of trust
now this is this is where the trust
comes into this conversation here
because when people feel that these
elements of dignity and I've got one
more but I want to want to stick with
benefit of the doubt because this is
where trust is lives in my model when
people feel that these other elements of
dignity are being violated the instant
we even have a even a certain look or a
tone of voice can trigger a dignity
violation then trust breaks down it's
the first reaction not only does trust
break down but secondly it creates
resentment when people feel that they've
been dishonored right so trust and I
think trust and resentment go hand in
hand here because it's the it's the part
that prevents people from state from
being in a relationship in a healthy way
or in an organization in a healthy way
and finally last but not least the last
element of dignity is the desire to be
apologized to when someone has done is
harm but I don't know if you're anything
like me sometimes giving an apology is
one of the hardest things even if you
know you were wrong right it's really
hard so I'm not saying any of these
things is easy they are all very very
difficult but the other thing that we
have to understand about this is that I
was just out of conference just in Notre
Dame where it was a group of people
interested in human development and the
thing is that we grow in flourish in the
context of
relationships that's where our
development happens and if our
relationships are not relationships that
are mutually honoring that understand
these significant elements of dignity
and all how we are all every human being
yearns to have these ten elements
honored in them and if they don't
relationships break down in a nanosecond
and keep in mind that relationships
actually are the source in the the
context of our development so we better
get this right you know we better if we
want good relationships and in the
workplace in the workplace I actually
believe that we spend so much time in
the workplace and it should be an
environment that promotes not only
protects but promotes human dignity
because dignity is the stuff of human
development it is what makes human
development flourish and happen we don't
have a sense of well-being unless we
have our dignity intact and in fact the
other day I was looking at that there
was this international happiness day and
I'm thinking you know what we need to
have an international dignity day
because there is no happiness without a
sense of dignity without the sense that
you're being treated well without an
internal sense of your own well-being
you can't you know so let's let's listen
okay net where's Michael we're gonna map
man well we're going to do this next
year right International dignity day
okay so want three things I want to tell
you about develop about dignity it's
about connection connection and
connection it's about connection to our
own sense of self-worth which is
fundamental the minute we lose that
connection to our self-worth we're in
trouble all sorts of morbid symptoms
appear after that connection to the
dignity of other people and thirdly as
it relates to your question about the
common good thirdly it's a connection of
something greater than ourselves and I
think dignity has those three dimensions
that are constantly interacting with us
as we go throughout our lives and I
think the workplace and humanistic
management paradigm release talk really
sheds light on this the workplace is the
place where this connection to a shared
purpose can be played out and that maybe
it's not even the common good maybe it's
just the shared purpose of what this
organization all agrees to aspire to
withhold what whatever the purpose is
but I'd like a reader could you give
them the handouts because I know I'm
running out of time but here's what I
again I'm hoping all the work that I've
done in the last 10 years is about
making this dignity work accessible and
practical and useful and I've developed
for organization something called a
dignity code of ethics which I just want
to leave you with all right because I
I'm you know I tend so often to go off
into the clouds thinking abstractly
about dignity view something concrete
can I just see the that yeah okay here
we go oh yeah what Lizzie yours is like
that okay so quick very very quickly
this is the this is a dignity code that
I work with people in organizations when
we're trying to promote a culture of
dignity when the leadership and here's
that the key element here when the
leadership has decided that they want to
integrate this dignity knowledge and
understanding into their culture okay so
what are the things that matter dignity
matters we're a company that recognizes
the importance of treating our employees
and customers in a way that honors their
value and Worth and the significant role
they play in the organization identity
matters we want our employees and
customers be proud to be a part of an
organization that puts recognition of
their value and worth at the center of
their brand and image leadership matters
we're a company whose leaders aspire to
lead with dignity and promote an
organizational culture of learning
through self-reflection and
accountability because there's nothing
worse when your leaders don't take
responsibility for ways in which they've
violated the dignity of the employees
fine and people matter we're a company
whose employees aspire to treat each
other with dignity and to promote an
organizational culture of learning both
same thing with as leaders through
self-reflection and accountability
relationships matter we're a company
that wants strong connection with all of
our workgroup
oops and are committed to building those
relationships on a foundation of dignity
the workplace matters we're a company
that people want to work for and where
they enjoy their jobs and each other we
strive to make the work environment one
where people feel free to speak up and
be heard without fear of recrimination
and finally I really think this is one
of the critical pieces of establishing a
culture of dignity because the fact is
we're going to mess up even if we have
dignity consciousness because we're
human beings were gonna we're going to
get lost every now and then we're going
to end up violating people's dignity we
are a company that recognizes that
conflict is a normal occurrence and as a
useful signal of the need for change we
are committed to establishing dialog
processes so that conflicts can be
managed in a dignified way ensuring that
people's concerns are heard and
acknowledged and we recognize that
managing conflict and the need for
change is key to the company's continued
growth and prosperity that's it
you